we have both admit in shock still we're
both sort of recovering from the full
force of seeing something that's taken
ten years to get to this point both of
real people's lives and other characters
stories and we're just it's it's peaches
is about thing to be in the middle of an
interview but it's that kind of feeling
how do you we were both trying to fight
back tears on stage it's terribly moving
it's why I was nearly crying you know
I've been such a huge fan of these
franchises since the beginning and I was
sitting on stage on the floor with the
Avengers watching Avengers that I'm in
yeah I can't believe it I genuinely I
nearly cried I genuinely nearly cried
I'm so glad to find out that you also at
any price though I wasn't the only one
really by magnitude yes manly did 90 92
a reaction of so many people where you
have Eider man that just came out so its
current people's minds I mean that
reaction could have broken glass and you
have whole can I remember talking to
mark and I was like when I first got
into it I was like what's this like and
it was like I'm on stage and I feel like
an idiot I don't know what I'm doing and
then I see the movie and I go oh my god
I'll do anything you want I'll do an a
kiddo do it whatever you want it doesn't
matter because what they're able to do
just with this cutting-edge technology
as well it makes every fantasy come true
literally it's fun to get the reveal you
know I haven't even seen the reveal you
know you're doing this stuff and it's
great conceptually and you're happy to
be a part of it and I know a lot of
these guys from you know we're all kind
of old school guys except for like the
Tom
spider-man like it he's a little kid but
it's really nice to be a part of it but
when you see the actual manifestation
it's fun I'm still reeling it's it's a
it's a really good time I mean you know
I think we really surprised the audience
with the footage it was intentional mr.
Peck
to make sure that they didn't expect it
and then when they finally realize they
were getting and I thought it was really
one for me one of the more special
moments I've had as a filmmaker I don't
I think like we don't even know what to
do right now that's the first time I've
seen anything we say anything so it's
speechless
it was pretty intense everybody seemed
to get way more than what they expected
it was just a very wide stage in a wide
audience
so it was massive it's like a like a
ocean of people out there and it was so
excited for literally every person that
came out you saw how much they loved
these movies and and the the Assembly of
all of us together it was it was
incredible it was incredible to watch it
it just it felt so special to have so
many of the amazing cast members of
Avengers all together and then there
were 7,000 people in the audience and
they were all Marvel fans that they were
screaming the house down and it just
felt like electricity I'm just so
grateful that I got to experience that
it was such a high yeah I mean it was
pretty pretty amazing and just to see
ten years of cinematic history converge
on one stage at this moment in time was
was awe-inspiring what is you know one
of the maddest things I ever ever just
did I I mean just walking out there and
seeing that many people because I have
this big the the camera shot because you
the sense that there about 100 people in
there yeah and then you I went out and
it was just in this enormous cavernous
very voice very wide there lot of people
hidden in the corners a lot of people
and a lot of screaming and it was it's
really exciting to see how people react
to me hear or see someone name or see
them on screen and it's really exciting
it's very special we talked about on the
stage today next year we our 10th
anniversary the first 10 years of Marvel
Studios it's been is beyond our wildest
dreams our dream was let's make a movie
ourselves
and that was Iron Man 1 and to be in
this position and Robert and I were just
talking about a backstage to be in this
position almost 10 years down the line
is incredible and bringing out on stage
today be 23 Avengers and guardians and
Doctor Strange and Black Panther and
spider-man is in the universe now it is
overwhelming and it was very very
humbling being out there for the d23
Expo today it really is an embarrassment
of riches and seeing this amazing
ensemble that we've assembled is is is
humbling I mean it really is it is I
think the best group and the biggest
group of actors ever assembled for a
single overarching storyline and having
them all they were shooting just
yesterday in Atlanta and they got on a
plane they flew all night they all came
out here and guess what they're all
going to fly back and keep working on it
but how could we pass up b23 is it I
mean it's fascinating because I think
it's an unprecedented experiment in
filmmaking where multiple franchises are
interwoven into one major narrative and
I think you know it's really special as
you know being able to you know write
the final chapters of that book with
these next two Avengers movies and you
know again as a comic book collector and
a fanboy I got to pinch myself sometimes
you